chappie must fight hi I'm Mike Cemil
from FX guide.com for wired in the new
film chappie
the world's first true AI robot never
actually of course acts on set he's a
fully digital character well we're a
workshop made some really great
reference and props every shot of
chappie interacting on screen is a full
digital replacement image engine did
about a thousand shots of chappie alone
which means the CGI chappie is seen on
screen for about 60 or 70 minutes of
screen height and while at least in the
film chappie is our one of a kind
behind the scenes one chappie did not
fit all you see on set the police robots
or Scouts were played by actors in grey
suits chappie was actually played by
actor Sharlto Copley while shelter we'll
the other actors were not motion
captured they were in fact animated by
hand each actor did perform with a small
GoPro camera and their camera footage
was then turned directly into the
footage or the vision that the robot
sees these GoPros are of course
set-and-forget so the production ended
up with hundreds of hours of robot
vision to work with Freddy given shot
the VFX team had to remove Sharlto then
create a clean plate and then animate in
chappie and of course all the
interactions that he has with the scene
Chris Harvey who was in charge of the
VFX work encouraged as much contact and
interaction in the scenes with chappie
as director Neill Blomkamp sought and
even when this made life a little
difficult the animators they thought it
really added to the scenes authenticity
chappie is made of multiple digital
assets in the film but as the film
progresses our hero gets shot firebombed
loses an arm and pimped-out and every
one of these action requires meticulous
tracking so in addition to the kind of
normal software that we use to manage
the animation production the team
actually needed to run a special
database to make sure that all the
continuity of various damages and
replacement arms even bling was
correctly tracked in fact as it becomes
very important in the film it's
level of chappies battery had to be
adjusted shop to shop to make sure the
characters timeline played out correctly
of course the team also had to make a
digital version of the moose and thanks
to some pretty serious moose attitude
issues clean up a lot of stunts and wire
rig removal from all those extensive
explosions and gun fighting in the end
by the time chappie grabs that grenade
belt you would have actually seen
seventeen chappies in chappie don't
forget to subscribe for more behind the
scenes action
I'm Mike Seymour four-wide time
consciousness I'm alive I am Joby